please if you're a studio executive you
are watching this everything is so
corporate
you know it's like what did francis ford
coppola say factory filmmaking just take
the drivers from fast and the furious
and put them in the transformers
cars i miss loving star wars i miss
loving it i used to love it yes i saw
wonder woman 1984. i want to know what's
going to happen next
and i and i can't tell you how many
times i've seen the first five or 10
minutes of a movie and i don't want to
watch the rest of it or if i could just
do the snap that thanos did i would get
rid of every franchise reboot
post probably
92.
you know where's the movie that we all
love without debate that we've all loved
please hollywood realize that it's not
going to work
would you say that 99 of all movies
today are garbage
in an age where
most movies are referred to as content i
would say that 99 of most movies
are pretty are pretty bad i always try
to like when when i say
99 i mean of mainstream
it really is when you look at and
especially i think one of the best
examples of this is the sort of uh uh
sac schneider's justice league and how
that was
you know bungled the the that how that
was bungled how the star wars franchise
was bungled how they could not
i mean to me i i i'm the studio
executive in charge of star wars and
we're making a new star wars movie and
the first thing i'm going to do is i'm
going to put han luke and leia in a
scene together and the fact that that
moment we will never be able to have
that moment in cinema when carrie fisher
was alive that to me is
i mean
that's
that's malpractice that's studio
malpractice the fact that they had with
zack snyder's vision what he was
building up to be i think seeing the
four-hour final product of what zack
snyder's justice league turned out to be
and that they made this garbage thing
joss whedon i mean
it's it's disheartening to me to see
that um
i will say on an indie level i tend to
take like a glass half full view and i
tend to always look for the positive
when it comes to indie films because you
cannot compare the
the the um you can't compare an indie
movie shot in 12 days for 10 000
to
justice league whichever version you're
talking about you can't compare because
in my mind there is no excuse for
a studio to fail when they put out a
blockbuster movie you have no excuse
your job is to entertain me not lecture
me
not lecture me your job is to entertain
unfortunately we live in a time you know
back in the day when
star wars was first made i feel like
they were checking one box it was called
fun
and now there's not only there's a
million boxes that must be checked there
are all sorts of noting and committees
and this thing and this is where you end
up with
um you know that last star wars movie by
j.j abrams is unwatchable i mean it's
it's it's garbage it's it's it's exactly
it informs exactly everything wrong with
the studio system
it's it's terrible so i look at like the
the the justice league debacle the the
the star wars franchise and how that has
been was mishandled and i look at that
and and i just think how could that have
been done where were the where where was
there ever like looking at like the fans
and what they think
you know um
what do the fans think of this stuff are
they satisfying the fans most normal
people don't care you know like like is
it entertaining taking my family
especially how expensive it is to the
movie theater experience which
is is going away
right the theatrical experience of
seeing a movie
um
is is going away you had better
entertain me
and i think that whether hollywood
notices it or not i think that people
don't really like politics woven into
fairly mainstream which should be
mainstream entertainment experiences
um and i think we're we're seeing that
more and more it's it's unbelievable to
me i think you're leaving money on the
table um for for not giving what the
customer is looking for in that
experience but
um so in my mind studios there's no
excuse to fail you have the best people
in marketing you have the most talented
actors
craftsmen when it comes to special
effects and cinematography
music there's no excuse for that to fail
and i think part of the failing of
hollywood is that the marketing is so
good sometimes
i've i've argued with friends sometimes
that i believe that that there should be
a key art i mean there are key art
awards you know for key movie poster art
i'm a fan of movie poster art there's a
really good documentary about movie
poster art called 24x36
check out that documentary um
but you know there there should almost
be a a marketing award and here's the
problem the conundrum
the marketing for some for these movies
is so good
the product doesn't live up to the
marketing
so
i mean i got chills watching the
trailers for the rise of skywalker i was
so excited to see that movie
the ninth i mean
i was a kid when i saw star wars i'm
seeing the ninth movie in this saga
i cannot believe how horrible it turned
out
it's it's it's really to me it's
malpractice
what happened to that franchise and how
it's divided fandom fighting over things
that are really
irrelevant i i think i think it's it's
well
not entirely irrelevant the fact that
they're just like you're seeing people
from within that company attack the fans
just like it's i
i hate to see it because i'm like
nerds are my people i go to san diego
comic-con every year i have since the
90s gone to san diego comic-con and so
to see people fractured over this is
really is really disheartening but
um
when it comes to studio movies there's
no excuse not to fail
now when it comes to small indie movies
to make a good movie under those
circumstances without the resources
without the money without the
great people in marketing without the
budget
without all of the best of circumstances
to make an indie movie that like
actually can can
you can be touched and moved by
that is something to be said which is
why i've always gravitated toward indie
film you know um it's a miracle when you
see something that's that's watchable
out of a studio
um but i don't i i don't know like where
the executives i mean other than like
maybe coming to mind like a kevin feige
which you know maybe his best days are
behind him you know i can't think of a
studio executive that is a visionary
these days are those the jocks the nerds
or the the nerds of the consumers yeah
the jocks yeah i mean when we look at
like the era the the the 70s being the
the um
last great era of american filmmaking we
really are um losing that american
identity because we become so fractured
as a culture
and i think that that
you know where's the movie that we all
love without debate that we've all loved
exactly i don't know that there is one
and and that's really
you know i i really and at the end of
the day i miss loving star wars i miss
loving it i used to love it and now i'm
saddened by
that franchise i'm using that as like
the best example there's a lot of other
examples we could talk about the
terminator franchise we could talk about
star trek we can talk about these these
sort of dead franchises that
have sort of lost their way
but when you look at like i just saw a
documentary called lady
laddi about alan ladd
the visionary
studio executive who basically greenlit
star wars and protected george lucas i'm
just afraid we're never going to see
another george lucas right we're never
going to see another real creative
visionary um that changes the industry
because everything is so corporate
you know it's like what did francis ford
coppola say factory filmmaking
that's that's the age in which we live
there's factory filmmaking which is a
product and content and then there's
up-and-coming indie filmmakers
and you know when i talked about
checking those boxes earlier a lot of it
is like is it going to appeal
international i mean let's let's be
honest the box office internationally
and especially in china is much bigger
than the united states that market those
dollars so you can't make a movie for
the united states anymore you have to
make a movie for the world which is fine
but i think in in a way that's sort of
diluting our identity
as as a people as americans as we become
more fractured and it's um
it's distressing to see you know you you
see it when it's like when it's like
god i was having a conversation with a
friend uh because of course the movies
are always an ongoing conversation with
friends um
if you're in my circle you'll it it will
come up and it's like when you look at
like when certain decisions are organic
or when you see when it's shoe horned in
right
when when certain things are shoe horned
in like um
like a say the the trope that's become a
trope now the strong female lead it's
just ripley was a great character like
just write a great character
not try to shoehorn in a type right and
you kind of know it when you see it you
go oh this is cliche this is a you're
trying to shoehorn in a type rather than
like that's just a great character
you're also talking to a guy when i ever
play a video game i always choose a
female character i don't know why i just
do that
as someone who has watched so many
movies as someone who has made their own
films
why do you think there's so many bad
films that are made
well
i look the reason there's so many bad
films um
these days is i think
one the barrier to entry is is much
easier but i also think that you're
they're on that that's on an indie level
i see bad indie films too right
i usually want to want to help them and
say this was your lesson
okay you'll make a better movie in your
second movie if you don't quit but when
it comes to studio films there's just
too many notes there are too many people
that um it's sort of you know the modern
day ball player right like it's just
like it's not about the passion for
playing the game i'm not a passion of
you know hitting the ball and hearing
the roar of the crowd it's
you know it's the licensing deals and
it's this and the sales of that and the
tv commercials and whatnot it's it's um
you know
i i i when i look back at the movie the
player which came out when i first moved
to los angeles robert altman's the
player
things haven't changed the subject has
changed i mean that was
sort of it was erotic thrillers and you
know it was julia roberts and bruce
willis were being cast in every movie
that was pitched in that film now it's
superhero movies but it's really too
many cooks and i feel like the people
being um you know elevated to these
positions
are good executives
but they're not people that know the
material the heart of the material and
when you look at the history of you know
creatives who really created something
like a george lucas or a gene
roddenberry
things begin to lose their way when they
get sidelined right you really need
those
i just i i feel like the modern
day hollywood now and especially with
streaming changing the game
theaters the survival of theaters being
in doubt
um really
we may live at a time where maybe the
billion-dollar blockbuster may not be
back for a long time
and that may end up being a good thing
right like
let's let's make
it's i always
i'll joke with a friend and i'll say my
favorite spider-man movie is the one
where mary jane is in peril at the end
which is pretty much all the spider-man
movies or my favorite science fiction
movie is the movie where that thing
blows up at the end
that's every science fiction movie
right
which is why and the empire strikes back
with such a because it wasn't about we
got to do and blow up the thing
that's
boring it's
it's just creatively bankrupt which is
why empire strikes back holds up
everybody says oh it's the best star
wars movie i mean you could argue but it
but um it's yeah because it didn't do
that thing that happened in all the
other movies
and and so trying to go against
doing that thing it's it's
or fighting a blue light there's a lot
of fighting a blue light that happens um
in films fighting a blue light
saving the person at the end the thing
that blows up at the end and i say defy
those cliches
at all costs
um and it's funny because you see like
you know there's still people that are
able to work within studio system and
deliver
worthwhile films um christopher nolan
being among them i've um quite admired
his work although he has a tendency to
make things a little overly complex for
no reason just to brag about how smart
he is but there's always a point in his
films and you'll notice that once i
pointed out where a character in a
christopher nolan movie will say we have
to go down the thing and grab the thing
to do this and shoot this it's it's
captain narrative right it's the person
that stops the movie to tell you what's
happening in the movie to explain what's
going to happen so the audience the dumb
audience understands it to me oh so you
got that studio now
studio note and he compromises in a way
that doesn't completely
destroy what he's trying to achieve as a
filmmaker so he's willing to play ball
but i just see and i think you know the
most recent example being zack snyder's
justice league and the fact that that
universe will remain unexplored
unfortunately um
which is disheartening uh
you look at that and i think part of the
reason that zack snyder's justice league
was suppressed was because
you know once it came out and you see
these are the choices the studio
executives made they decided to hire
joss whedon they decided to change
everything about it in in in you know in
exchange for this like it makes them
look bad
right because what zack snyder was
trying to do is much much better
um clearly
whether you enjoy it personally or not
it was objectively much better than what
joss whedon ended up coming up with
which was effectively a dumb cartoon a
live-action dumb cartoon
so
what about adaptations
do you think that that's has that always
been around or is that adaptations
adaptations of popular books not not
necessarily doesn't have to be a
franchise but you know well i mean think
about think about it it's here's what's
dead is originality i mean people forget
what george lucas created in star wars
was something completely original i mean
yes it was influenced by so many things
westerns you know flash gordon and buck
rogers cereals and whatnot but
but almost
nothing
that you see
isn't
nothing that you see in the studio realm
it's all based on something pre-existing
material
it's a book a graphic novel a comic book
a thing that kind of proved the concept
right
and then or a franchise right it's a
thing that you know whether it's star
wars star trek
whatever um
you know comic book characters that have
been around for years it's very rare
that there'll be something that's a
wholly original concept um
so i kind of uh you know i i
really it would really be interesting if
studios rolled the dice more to get
something like a joker what todd
phillips did with the joker right that
joker film which was a low-budget movie
right i mean um
i chatted with him about it i'm sure you
can look up quotes todd phillips talking
about how he he pitched them doing some
sort of dc black series it would be
these sort of one-off films that would
be stories that didn't really fit with
any sort of larger continuity that were
like smaller movies we could explore a
part of that universe
um and the fact that that movie did so
well you know from
being praised from uh uh you know in
terms of at award season i think is um
proves his concept was was the right way
to go and people forget todd phillips
came from independent film
you know he i knew him back in the day
when he was making documentaries he
famously has that um frat house
documentary that played sundance and
then never was released
so um i think you can find it on youtube
um what about mink what's that what
about mink mink yeah i don't know how
you make a mink you know like here's the
thing i look at mank and i'm like i love
menk but i
went to film school and i've seen
citizen kane 100 times and i've read
books about citizen kane and
one of my one of my favorite dvd
commentaries is the one that roger ebert
did for citizen kane um so i know
a lot of the back story and i feel like
it's almost impossible to watch mank you
have to watch citizen kane maybe watch
citizen kane first and then watch mank
and then re-watch citizen kane um but
yeah i think mank is incredible
you know um
but i think it's for i think mank is for
film nerds i mean i think it's brilliant
that david fincher was able to get that
film made in the way that he made it you
know it's sort of an it's sort of a
story about the genre made within the
style of the old school genre
but with modern tools and then sort of
laced with political commentary maybe a
bit too heavy-handed at times
um but um
i i really enjoyed mank
but it's not that's not a mainstream
audience movie so kudos to uh kudos to
netflix for that
um
but yeah most of i wouldn't say that you
know i like to be an optimist so i don't
know that 99 of the studio movies are
bad maybe it's more like 97
we can we can quibble about the
percentages but
you know stuff leaks through
that could be an ongoing podcast
why 99 of movies are garbage it's really
documenting all the mistakes that
filmmakers make
i think i think one that i've seen as a
trend that i think i failed to mention
in the previous video was the
gender swapping of of
characters i think that um
i mean
you know i i've seen how people think
that that's a well we'll just do a
female terminator or we'll just do a
female you know a female version of x
i always think it it's better to start
with an original character
and have a
and and and approach it approach a film
that way um i find it kind of pandering
on on hollywood's part to just we're
just going to do this franchise which we
already know is proven success and we're
going to gender swap the lead
i think i i think that's lazy
i think it's pandering to a certain
audience and that audience may not even
really be there
and i think that that fans of those
franchises completely see through that
it's it's um
you know i mean the latest uh that mad
max movie that we did that that they did
uh recently um
fury road
he's really kind of the side character
but what charlize theron did she created
this amazing
new character i think they kind of that
was maybe the right way of doing that
the wrong way
might have been the the you know
terminator film dark fate
um
which i'm not sure who loved that movie
um i know it didn't do too well at the
box office
i mean um
sarah connor is already
um an amazing character i don't know why
you need to you know uh
flip things
and gender swap i think again i i think
audiences see audiences see through that
um an example we talked about this
earlier was um
you know one that thankfully
they'll hopefully never do
which is back to the future
there's been rumblings of bringing the
back to the future series and doing a
reboot of back to the future there was a
rumor years ago and i pay very little
attention to rumors
because most of them we all know are bs
but there was a strong rumor that justin
bieber was going to be
in a reboot
of the back to the future series but
that's a franchise you i don't think you
could ever
you could ever gender swap
the lead
the lead like and call that lead mandy
mcfly
and having some sort of weird
relationship with a younger version of
her father would be very awkward
i mean that just doesn't work and and
then there are cases where gender
swapping is irrelevant
um for example the upcoming dune movie
um with timothy chalamet
there's a character named dr liet kinds
which i've read the novel
obviously seen the uh 1984
david lynch film
the gender of that character is
absolutely irrelevant not relevant to
the character whatsoever
in in that case
um
uh maybe in in in some ways can kind of
add to something when you're doing it
just to pander to an audience
audiences see through it i i really see
it i really feel that when you are
pandering
um whether it's queerbaiting or
you know gender-swapping characters or
race-swapping
it's lazy it's lazy
you know i'd rather see
more
original
characters
that
are are you know maybe by female
creators
black creators
where are their voices if you're simply
taking you know creators who have done
things and just changing the gender or
race i find is lazy in that and i i
think that audiences
they're they're not really in favor of
it you know
um
it it seems to not be working
and i i think i think
if hollywood just leaned a little bit
into originality
a little bit more into originality
and took some risks
with new creators see that's the thing
that i think people don't understand is
that the original creators of those
characters they get money
right
they get money
and so i don't understand why there's
not more of an effort to find people who
have created
original characters
um
that are
all across the spectrum of ethnicity or
gender
and
and make and make movies with those
characters right i mean the original
creators of those properties would
profit
so
i i think pandering is probably
a a huge mistake
and
underestimated how savvy audiences are
that they see through it
so if i come in and say i want to do a
male version of heather's or jennifer's
body
or
mean girls you know i mean hey there's
mount there's male bullying there's all
sorts of stuff so it's john's body okay
sure
that's not that's not probably gonna
work
or it's so blatant that i'm flipping it
here's the thing i've seen that story so
i've seen those stories changing the
gender is not gonna is sort of you know
make me care about the character because
the point is is this i you know i i
identify with so many characters that
aren't me
right and i think that
you have to create something that comes
from the essence of what that character
is ripley is a character i loved as a
kid ellen ripley
played
beautifully by sigourney weaver
in
two and a half good movies
but
but but
you know i i i think that just the the
sort of you know i think it's just lazy
to do that but it's an opportunity for
an audience to identify with someone
that isn't them and i feel like you have
to as an audience
member be capable of
seeing the world through someone else's
eyes and i i've said this before i don't
know if i've said it but in another
video but like
you have to as an audience member have
the ability to identify with someone
who's not you that's how you know even
the storytelling is great
if you can take just sort of a
regular dude like me
and i can identify
with a woman who's maybe not a woman
who's white so maybe not a woman from
the united states
who's maybe a woman that's going
that to me is great storytelling
i would say another film that i
thoroughly loved
amelie
french film amelie right okay
not a woman i don't speak french
you know a lot of her experiences very
different from mine
but i identified with her i was on her
journey
uh
and so that to me is you know
storytelling is great when
you know
vastly different people can identify
with someone that is not
is not themselves i don't need to see me
reflected in a film in fact i prefer not
to you know i want to see someone new
and interesting and different
and
i think that what's lacking in the
storytelling is
is
is making these stories universal so the
gender and ethnicity is irrelevant it
should be irrelevant
yeah i mean just you had said earlier
about the the marty mcfly character
turned into danny mcfly and you're right
it it wouldn't work for the especially
for the one
fact of of flipping it with the dad now
to have a biff character that's female
that's bullying her that actually would
be interesting and and and then her sort
of going on this journey and playing in
a band see now you're being like a
studio executive and you're you're
pitching the female back to the future
please please
please i will say this to camera which i
know
my eye line is you but i'm going to say
the camera please if you're a studio
executive you're watching this
do not ruin back to the future
do not ruin back to the future by making
a female back to the future it would be
terrible
think about it deeply this is not a good
idea
seek out original ideas from original
creators who have original stories to
tell
please
so i don't have to do
a third version of this video please
why are there so many bad sequels
there are so many bad sequels because i
feel like
the essence of what made
the original
so interesting
is the thing that's not really focused
on usually what's focused on in a sequel
is more
and it's more spectacle
not the thing that made it compelling to
begin with i think the way to
answer this question is to look at the
sequels that
that you know succeeded
um
films like the godfather two
right godfather two
you know was
an even more complex film than the
original godfather
it tells it it plays with time where
you're having two stories being told
simultaneously the story of vito
corleone his rise to power uh you know
along with you know the pres the
present-day michael corleone
who's you know you're seeing his story
play out in present-day that the story
is being told
um and it's also different and it's
original in the same way that the first
godfather was original i could apply
that same thing to star wars and the
empire strikes back
the empire strikes back ended on a
cliffhanger the original star wars ended
with this triumphant ending the good
guys win when did the good guys ever
lose
in a fairy tale
generally never
but the empire strikes back did that it
didn't even tell a complete story
you know and at the time you had to wait
three years to to see what the
conclusion of that story would be
so
doing something original and different
rather than more of the same
which would have been let's have another
death star
which of course they did twice more in
star wars films
you know i mean maybe three times if you
want to count rogue one
but going over old territory
is boring
and i feel like what you need to do is
in the same way that the original film
was a risk in doing something original
if you're going to do a sequel you also
need to take risks and do something
different um i would i would say that
um this doesn't apply as much but with
alien and aliens um alien directed by
ridley scott um aliens uh james cameron
one's more horror set in outer space the
other one is action movie
more aliens
right but it's a different type of film
um
and a continuation of that story told um
with with some originality that's
another sequel that holds up
but so many other sequels
that i have not named
are terrible for the very reason that
they just
try to give you more of what was in the
first one rather than you know defy your
expectations
and and that i think has to do with
fear on the part of the filmmakers
and not really trusting the audience i
think you need to trust the audience
that they want to see these beloved
characters
from the first film in new and different
situations things that are challenging
to those characters
and and you don't often see that in
sequels it's just
[Music]
more i think that's lazy
as much as the fast and the furious
movies are financially successful i
don't know if
you could call any of them critically
acclaimed
those films tend to do well but it's
just more
craziness
it's more over the top it's more
in the last one they go to outer space
how much more over the top can you get
it's just it's ridiculous now
i mean at this point just take you know
a friend of mine once suggested just
take the drivers from fast and the
furious
and put them in the transformers
cars
they're driving the transformers cars
why not combine franchises
it would at least be original right
but i i think if you're going to do a
sequel
you've got to do something different and
original because that's
keeping with
the characters i need to challenge the
characters in ways they were not
challenged in the first film
and i'm not saying that's something easy
but when you look at what a successful
sequel is
compared to one that is completely
forgettable
they made of the fly too
the fly with jeff goldblum they made a
sequel to it
gina davis's character dies in like the
opening scene no one there there's many
sequels i could i could name off the top
of my head you would not even remember
that there was a sequel the highland
highlander two
there was a sequel i think there's like
nine of those
but the only one that really holds up is
the first one
so
it's it's very tricky it's very tricky i
i feel like it's important to
to
be original in the same way that the
first one
what what people liked about that flip
that defy expectations
i'll go back several decades
but uh staying alive and saturday night
fever and i know i'm really dating
myself here but both fantastic films
staying alive to me
um i'm sorry yeah staying alive was was
a little bit better in my sense than
than saturday night fever just because i
enjoyed john travolta's journey staying
in this crummy hotel he's this hungry
dancer he meets finola hughes who's got
this upper hand and can help him but
there are strings attached it's just a
fantastic cast of characters and to me
i thought that the the storytelling was
was richer but again that's it's going
back several years it's not a franchise
i understand that some of the viewers
may not know that movie but uh i thought
that the storytelling was was way better
but
i
yeah do you remember that
i remember it
and uh i wish i could forget it oh you
do okay it was that bad no um it just
that i mean
that film i just remember the phenomenon
being the music i remember it was
r-rated and i could not go see it
so okay you know at the the time that uh
saturday night fever came out sure sure
yes i think i remember that too but i
think i saw it when i was a little bit
older but
the staying alive
for me just i thought that the
continuation of his journey as this like
you know here he was this hot shot back
home but then he goes to the big city
and he's just this small fish in this
very very treacherous pond where no
one's trustworthy and everybody has
their own agenda and the gir the good
girl cynthia gibbs she actually seems
like the best character and he's like
whatever with you because she can't she
can't get him anywhere so i just thought
it was just a great play on
on things but yeah i i realize that's
not a franchise
um that's a great cameo from sylvester
stallone in the beginning by the way so
i mean look here's here's here's another
reason to me that sequels tend to suck
is that
the first film generally
is is made to not be a series the first
film is is is being made to tell a story
and it's usually being made
for a reason that this is there's
there's meaning behind it
there's purpose on on behalf of the
filmmaker that wants to tell a story
that has themes that are woven into the
film that that the filmmaker wants to
express
so
generally
an original film that ends up being a
you know part of a series
unintentionally
you know
that that original film is being made
out of some
reason that that is artistic
and sequels are made for money
so by you know by that very you know
because of that dynamic sequels are made
for money
original films
that end up being part of a series are
usually made to express
something an artist is trying to say
um that always mucks up what a sequel
will be
interestingly
yes i am going to come back to star wars
george lucas
had alan dean foster
come up with a story for a low-budget
independent
sequel to star wars which was to be
called splinter of the mind's eye
it ended up being a novel
you can find it used in a bookstore
yeah a bookstore probably a used
bookstore
you know go into one they're great
books are these things it's like the
internet but on really thin slices of
wood
try it someday in any case this book was
written to be a low budget sequel to
star wars because what george lucas
wanted to do is you know if star wars
bombed he wanted to make a small indie
follow-up to that movie to continue the
series
uh and he wanted it written in a way
that that could be done inexpensively
it's really interesting to see what
what star wars might have been
if splinter the mind's eye was made as a
low-budget indie movie um
uh there's
love to see a lot of those but
but but but you know i i truly believe
that
sequels because they are made
purely because accountants at a studio
say
this will make money
because if it makes 40 of the original
it'll be in profits if we scale the
budget to this which is why the budgets
generally for sequels are less
money
being spent than the original
uh you know because there is a formula
used by studios
to say well the movie made x the first
movie made x
if we scale the budget
to this
and it just makes even 40 of the
original
will be in profits
you know that old formula is different
these days now with um
with so many other pathways for films to
make money but
but
generally the sequel the budget is less
did you see wonder woman 1984
yes i saw wonder woman in 1984. okay uh
first off did you used to watch the show
i did i did used to watch the linda
carter show and i love that show okay uh
it's it's it's fun it's you know it's
wholesome
um there's
a weird subtext i didn't notice when i
was a kid but now i see it
if you know something about
the history of wonder woman and that
character but uh but yes i saw wonder
woman and i did see wonder woman 1984.
is this pg-13 can you tell me the
subtext
well it's all about
it's all about bdsm and fetish stuff it
was always like wonder woman getting
tied up or wonder woman tying up with
the lasso gotcha you know whoever the
adversary was to make them tell the
truth okay it was um
this is not an original thought of mine
this is all very well documented go down
your own rabbit hole on the internet but
uh
feel free to jump off
okay at some point so aside from the s m
angle to it um
which that's its own show
what what do you what do you think uh
fell short in 1984 the second i think
what fell short was
was logic on behalf of the filmmakers i
mean they really there was a the thing
that really fell short was a
believability
um
you know you can wish things and they
come true i think it's kind of a maybe
an idea that should have been vetted it
sounds kind of
sounds kind of dumb to me like it just i
just didn't believe it whereas yeah i
believe a woman who's an amazonian
could be imbued with these powers but
wonder woman isn't wonder woman because
of her powers she's because of her
because of her character and her
morality
um
because of her commitment to you know
defending those that are powerless you
know against the from the powerful
and i feel that that essence of her
character was kind of captured maybe a
little bit in the opening scene which i
thought was kind of cute and clever and
and the opening scene of wonder woman 84
is kind of harking back to a richard
donner
superman you know
i i i enjoyed that it was kind of cute
and goofy
i'll take it it's fine once it got into
the the main plot with uh pedro pascal
just sort of defied logic and and the
the way that
that uh you know
you know chris pine's character was
brought back it was i just thought was
ridiculous i i don't
i don't know if the gender was reversed
it was done the other way it might have
worked it might even be somewhat
offensive
you know
sort of like if they made a female back
to the future
let's say if they they rebooted the
franchise let's say we're going to
reboot the franchise back to the future
let's just think about how we would do
that right
and it's a female back to the future
sure and marty her name is mandy right
and she goes back
and there's a sexual tension between her
dad or who will be her dad a younger
version of her dad i don't think that
will work yeah that's a little creepy
it's a little creepy
so maybe it's a really good thing
it's a good thing
that back to the future franchise may be
one of the only franchises that will not
be rebooted because if you did reboot
back to the future with a female
mandy
right
and well i guess it could be doc brown
not gonna work it just doesn't work
sure please hollywood realize that it's
not going to work
because we've seen these franchises get
rebooted
and it's disheartening to me when you
see the number of movies made it's
always based on pre-existing material
and the reason hollywood does this is
because ideas must be vetted in some
form
it was a play it was a novel
it's a franchise which is generally the
answer it's a franchise that's existed
for 80 years 50 years 40 years whatever
it is right like it's vetted
if you're going to invest that kind of
money you know it's just it's
you know
you want to make sure you have your best
chance of being profitable
so i understand from their thinking but
it really does
it does quell what might be
some amazing original ideas that's why i
i i
i'm
upset that we may never see a type of
filmmaker like george lucas again of
creating a fantasy world from nothing
um as an original series of movies
i mean star wars was certainly inspired
by everything from marvel comics dr
doom's character darth vader
from flash gordon
uh the serials
from
dune
the book by frank herbert
uh
it was inspired by so many things it's
like a blender of all this cool
into something that's original
and
risk is
not
something
hollywood likes
let's talk about killing iconic
characters
when is it okay when is it a horrible
mistake
i think it's really important if you
want to retain the audience for a
franchise
how you
kill off an iconic movie character
absolutely critical
and there are places in movie history
where it's been done right and there are
places where it's been done completely
wrong and it's been bungled
i
i i i it's it's upsetting to me i mean
first of all the death of an iconic
fictional character is already upsetting
just on its face
let's talk about a case in which it was
done
incredibly well
in star trek ii the wrath of khan
you're taking leonard nimoy's character
spock
who he'd played you know for decades by
then
and
you're now killing off this character
you're killing off spock
it's handled so well
it's not a wasteful death spock dies in
an act of self-sacrifice
trying to save the crew of the
enterprise which he'd done many times
before
and skirted death now he's
you know dying in the engine room of the
enterprise
facing his best friend
jim kirk
because the important thing to remember
and this is something for screenwriters
to keep in mind
is that the death of the character is
not about the person doing the dying
it's about the reaction
of the characters that love the
character
that's
that's going through
and experiencing their death
and so what we got to experience as an
audience
was two longtime friends
and an active self-sacrifice spock is
dying and he gets to say his final words
to kirk
and kirk gets to see his friend
in addition to that that scene is
followed up with a funeral
with some glorious music and and
i mean we didn't know at the time that
they were setting up a sequel
star trek three the search for spock
which kind of gives it away that spock
might be coming back but
be that as it may
no one's ever dead in in
fiction
but the way that that death was handled
with was handled with such respect for
all the characters involved
we got it was a satisfying in the sense
that we
experienced the love that
james t kirk has for his friend spock
and
then the reactions of people
who loved spock and and how they were
affected by his death his death had
meaning
conversely
one of the worst deaths ever handled in
movie history
was the death of han solo in the force
awakens
you know many people were upset with the
last jedi and how luke skywalker's
character was handled but
the thing that lost it for me was
han solo's death and the force awakens
it's not done in any sort of act of
self-sacrifice
there isn't a moment
where other characters
can react
to han solo's death
he's simply
you know dispensed with by his own son
ben solo with a lightsaber to the heart
and then falls down an endless chasm
generally falling down an endless chasm
is the kind of death that usually a
villain experiences
leading cause of death amongst villains
i'm sure there's an infographic
somewhere on the internet that will tell
you this because that's how the emperor
died in the original uh return of the
jedi episode six
that's how villains go out
falling into an endless chasm we don't
really see the bloodiness it's
off-screen
that's how a villain goes out and to
have han solo die in that way and not
have a last moment with chewbacca
his loyal friend
to not have a last moment
with princess leia or luke skywalker
the audience was completely betrayed of
any meaning for that death
was betrayed by not being able to see
our beloved characters who
just if you're watching all the movies
in in order
a few hours ago was alive and well and
saving the universe
and
my god if there was a child and we had
just finished watching return of the
jedi i don't know that i'd want to skip
to the next movie to see what happens
because what happened how the character
of han solo was treated
in his death in the force awakens was
offensive to me
and told me that this franchise was in
the wrong hands
because you can't take a character like
that and have him go out that way you
know it's not it's not a bad thing and
this used to be yes it's a hollywood
trope you know riding off into the
sunset was was
a fine way to go
right it worked for shane
it worked it worked for many iconic
hollywood films we're gonna ride off
into the sunset maybe we don't need to
see the death we can imagine other
adventures with that character but their
story has been told and they can ride
off into the sunset but if you're
actually going to kill an iconic
character
it needs to be done with some level of
respect
and every way that that could have been
handled in a much better way which would
be the
to have some final words
um they could have even done it in that
movie he could have been mortally
wounded by ben thinking he could have
turned his son back
from the dark side to the light
and he was mortally wounded
and you can imagine a scene with luke
skywalker and princess leia over you
know a dying han solo
and what the words that might have been
said we'll never see that now
so i
i i'm just
i'm just offended by that and so i think
that that's if you look at those two
cases of spock and his sacrifice in star
trek ii the wrath of khan just go watch
that scene
and then you compare it with the scene
of han solo
meaningless without even a funeral and
even though the when when when rey
returns and you know there's the
knowledge that han solo
you know is dead
she she just goes to hug ray not not
like you know chewbacca who she's
known for decades i know that i don't
understand
so i really question the thinking of
some of the people in charge
who are overseeing some of these beloved
franchises
um and how that affected not just
children
who these movies are really made for
children or for older dudes like myself
who saw the classic films as a kid
and would at least like these characters
to be treated with some level of respect
george lucas famously
consulted a child psychologist when he
toyed with the idea of making darth
vader the father of the hero of his
movie
right
he he was i don't know i want to see how
this is going to affect kids was there
any vetting done by how this might
affect the audience if you're going to
handle this death in that way
and in each of the sequel trilogy movies
the deaths of the characters
are are are
handled with this
not not using what i would consider to
be a respectful death which is there
needs to be someone to react to that
death that is meaningful in that in that
character's life
and of course spock's best friend in the
universe was jim kirk
so when he made that sacrifice it was
meaningful
and han solo's sacrifice seemed like a
waste
something else that occurs to me also
related to star wars yes a recurring
topic in conversations that i will have
with you
and that i have with my friends often
you know maybe it's a form of therapy
but but what was interesting was
that when george lucas
was mapping out the story for the empire
strikes back
he realized that the audience would
never believe
that
you would kill luke skywalker
so you have this lightsaber duel
at the end of the empire strikes back
and it's luke skywalker fighting darth
vader where's the tension
because we already know he's making a
trilogy
you're not going to kill off luke
skywalker
so there's really no drama or tension in
that scene so what lucas did he's like
okay since they
the audience is not going to believe
that i would kill luke skywalker
what if the real drama the real threat
is that luke might turn to the dark side
and because he he he doesn't listen to
yoda's advice he doesn't complete his
training he goes off as a as as not a
fully trained jedi
and faces his greatest nemesis who he
then learns at the end of the after
losing that fight that it's his father
could he turn to the dark side and and
george lucas believed that the audience
might believe that he would turn to the
dark side and and therein lies the
tension whereas
many of the lightsaber duels that take
place in
in the sequel trilogy are
are kind of meaningless
so it's important
for these characters
and i would say that if you're a disney
shareholder you probably care even more
if you want a franchise to to continue
to exist and be profitable and you want
to sell more han solo shirts
and whatnot that that the deaths of
iconic movie characters be treated with
respect
and
it's an opportunity not just for the
fictional characters that love that
character in that world to say goodbye
it's an opportunity for the audience to
say goodbye as well
reminds me of a film uh i watched
recently i think or late 90s early 2000s
and it's about a hollywood producer and
it shows a test screening and sean penn
is one of the the characters in the film
playing
you know he is sean penn in the movie
and it's the famous thing of
at the end he gets killed but does his
dog so they show it to this test
audience and they're horrified and it's
a horrific scene it's awful and so that
is the big dilemma in the film do we
keep that scene in
and i think robert de niro plays the
hollywood producer i think it's called
like what the hell happened or something
like that it's got an all-star cast but
where i'm going with this is
test screenings and audience feedback
if you feel this way and other fans do
as well
why was nothing done why was the respect
given to one character dying not so for
the other i mean i mean there's um
there's actually um interesting
documentary that i just saw about alan
ladd jr called lady
uh it's it's actually uh made by his
daughter
and of course alan ladd jr was
instrumental in getting star wars made
but he famously gave a lot of notes to
to movies um like the exorcist and
whatnot like he would give very small
notes he wasn't like telling filmmakers
what to do
he was more like okay we're watching
this in a screening room and like okay
but there's this element missing
sometimes it's you know it's important
to take that step back
and i do believe that test audiences
test audiences can actually help improve
a film
um i know that uh you know for example
you know i mean they call them focus
groups
um quentin tarantino has a more colorful
colorful term for focus groups he calls
them fuckus groups but
i know i said i wouldn't swear um but
but uh
but i think that i think that it's
important to
you know
to to keep those kinds of feelings and
there's a lot of feelings wrapped up
in in
an audience's experience with this
that's why i think these these death
scenes are so
so critical the approach to it
i i'm just surprised that
the legacy characters from the previous
trilogy which if you're doing a marathon
or just
you know were treated so poorly
um that there
there wasn't as much thought given to
that
you know
um i you know
you people have invested we're talking
about the movies here but also we're
also talking about there are comic book
stories about these characters there are
stories i've made up in my mind
about these characters
yes when i played with action figures
when i was a kid
you know
um
there are stories we made up in our
heads there are novels
there are radio plays
there are all sorts of stories that this
that these iconic characters have
you know have participated in and and
we've experienced those we there's a lot
invested
so the callousness with which that was
done
is
shocking to me
to this day
i tend to connect with people the
easiest way to connect is through a
passion for film and all types of film i
really am i do think it's important that
we have
a balanced media diet
oh what is that a balanced media diet is
absolutely critical
in the same way that what we put into
our bodies is just as important if you
lived only on fast food say hollywood
blockbuster movies
i find that um
first of all if you only ate mcdonald's
there's already been a movie made about
that and it doesn't do good things to
your body right like fast food greasy
food not good for you
balance
and i feel like
we don't pay enough attention to our
media diet and the media diet has to be
yes fine i'm gonna go see that marvel
movie right
i'm gonna go see that movie that a lot
of movie these days they're just like
theme park rides they're not movies
right they're selling products and i'm
gonna balance that out by seeing a
really amazing documentary or a small
independent film made by a filmmaker
i've never heard of put out like by a
gravitas ventures or something or a 1091
or 824 one of these other companies well
824 is warner brothers that's another
story but the orchard the orchard yeah
a24 is very good taste if you ask oh
they do i i really do love their the
their how they curate the films that
they put out or an ifc participant yeah
yeah like like
have a balanced media diet if you
there's a whole group of youtubers
that are on that that have made a living
on giant franchises and i say
i agree with first of all i agree with
many of them those franchises are
terrible the modern incarnations of some
of these franchises that have been
around more than 20 years
they've sort of run it into the ground
um but i feel like maybe you wouldn't be
as
upset about them if you had a balanced
media diet meaning
meaning yeah i'll see the latest
whatever forgettable big blockbuster
movie but because i have seen some
smaller film this is a weird example
psycho gourmand
you know or um a movie a documentary i
would highly recommend called clapboard
jungle which is about um
it's about a filmmaker's journey
uh trying to you know
actually find a way to make
money in this in crazy industry i think
you need to have a balanced media diet
and that's
at least what my mission is with film
thread is we tend to champion filmmakers
who make these smaller movies
because there are
plenty of other websites that cover star
wars marvel pixar disney
right
um those are all one company if i right
marvel pixar star wars disney that's all
one company putting out the stuff there
really is a monopoly it's it's
unfortunate that these big blockbusters
have that um but
but
those are okay to see
but you should not only see those it's
just like you know within like see one
of those and then see a smaller film see
one of those see a documentary see one
of those see another documentary like
break it up and really look like whether
it's like you're scrolling through
itunes or vudu or whatever one of those
services where you can purchase or rent
movies and look at the you know video on
demand stuff that's just come out you're
gonna find some incredible stuff
and and that's where i feel very
fortunate and that's part of our mission
um
is to say look at these movies because
if you only lived off the
giant franchise films you will find only
disappointment
and so and so break it up a bit maybe
you won't be as upset about that so
um
have a balanced media diet so there's
four food groups
and there's four
like you know you have your blockbusters
you have your documentaries you have
your art house and then maybe something
with subtitles
sure okay
i actually you know what i will say this
i put subtitles on when i don't have to
because you learn so much when i watched
game of thrones i knew all the
characters names because i watched it
with with the closed captioning on
uh it's great it's it's really it's
really fantastic so i actually recommend
closed captioning even if it's a film
that's in your the the language that
you're familiar with your native
language is it's uh you you
you'll you'll learn more um because
especially because a lot of it is like
you'll get some of the direction that's
directly out of the screenplay right
like like it's really useful and
thinking like a writer i think that
watching a movie with closed captioning
on in english even if you are an english
speaker
is really useful uh
so i tend to do that
i don't know is that
i don't know if that's a thing i do it
uh my thing i have friends who think i'm
crazy for doing it i find it incredibly
um
you'll learn a lot more about what
you're watching
i like ideas that uh provoke my
sensibilities you know um
i like some something a piece of art
that will challenge me
um i know that there's you know i i feel
that like there's a lot of um
you know to me fiction
fiction is all about um
uh being able to identify with whoever
or whatever is on screen whether that
person that i'm seeing in this work of
fiction whether it's a book movie
television show whatever it is
i don't need to be that person i just
need to identify with that person it may
not be my same gender may not be the
same ethnicity or nationality as me and
not speak the same language as i
may not even be human
right
but the point of all fiction is that we
identify with
the protagonist
and it doesn't have to match who i am in
fact i prefer that usually doesn't
i mean
i remember being mocked
when i was younger whenever i play video
games i always chose female characters i
don't know why
i think i just like to look at the
female form in a video game but i always
chose the female characters um i i tend
to
i'm playing right now the video game i'm
playing and obsessed with and it's been
wrongly
i think mocked for a lot of its
technical issues is the the game
cyberpunk 2077 which i think is a
brilliant brilliant game it really
immerses you in this
you know open world adventure game
um and i'm playing as a female version
of a character and i i think it's i
think it's amazing i think that there's
um
i i think i think we learn by
identifying with someone who
who doesn't match my my exact
circumstances i think a lot of this
comes from my mother
um
when i was younger and i would just
see whatever mainstream stuff was at the
movie theater i lived bicycle distance
to a movie theater where i grew up in
royal oak michigan
and i would ride my bike to the berkeley
theater
or the main theater
or the americana theater which was a
further bike ride but i would i would i
would go see movies and
she would tell me don't just go see
movies that are at the mall theater go
to the art house she encouraged me to go
to the maple theater which was where
their art house theater was
and i saw films that had subtitles
you know i mean i grew up watching a lot
of uh uh toho monster movies right and
and
you know
japanese television shows
so i had this you know by the time i was
like in my late teens early 20s i'd seen
a lot of foreign films and a lot of a
lot of
just different types of movies across
the board not just your traditional big
mainstream movies like your star wars
and your alien and and
you know disney cartoons and whatnot
so
back to having a balanced media diet and
i think that's important and
i think it's important and i think i
think i know when a writer's been
successful when someone that i would not
have ever had that experience where i
can just be totally with that person
um experiencing the world through their
eyes and i'm i don't look like that
person i think that is really powerful
to be able to create a character
protagonist that anyone can identify
with
so i think that's important to keep in
mind
here's a thought have movies lost their
cool because television has become so
good so if you think back to growing up
tv
was was more restricted and and
everything cool happened in movies like
kramer versus kramer ooh there were some
scenes that i wasn't supposed to see but
i saw them anyway right um now you can
see it all on tv
yeah i i do think that television
has succeeded so well when it comes to
you know long-form storytelling
i do think that there is a bit of abuse
in that where i've seen series that were
six episodes six hours that would have
made a really good two hour movie
uh
but i i think that there's an appetite
for uh the serialized long-form
storytelling and and we've become used
to that we've become used to the binge
watching so going to the theater to see
you know a story that's gonna wrap
itself up in hopefully two hours
um
maybe it's not as satisfying and even
you know when you look at uh the star
wars films or the marvel movies it
really is just every marvel movie is a
continuation of the last marvel movie in
some form because we know there's going
to be easter eggs we know there's going
to be you know cameos from characters
so
marvel movies in a sense have become not
only its own genre
but you know a sort of a form of
long-form storytelling with the disney
plus series
the
you know those kind of filling in the
blanks between movies
um but i think that television is is
great i mean television is where um
nudity in movies has migrated
there's hardly nudity in films anymore i
mean it's it's you know you're gonna
sacrifice something at the box office if
you choose to include adult themes in
your
feature film being released to theaters
if there's nudity in it
you know um that has migrated onto
television you know it's a golden as mr
skin who was recently on the film threat
podcast told me it's a golden age of
nudity in television not so much at the
movies
um
you know there aren't like the genre of
teen sex comedy kind of doesn't even
exist
people people forget that the original
porky's film such as it was um yes
it does feature
nudity
but also there's a
you know underlying message of
anti-semitism
woven within that film that of course no
one remembers
except for me i remember this i don't
know why
i remember weird facts
but that but um
you know maybe this is also
why television
part of the reason that television
in a way is more popular than than films
i don't know if anyone's ever done this
study i would love to see because i
think box office is an irrelevant metric
by which to
to
look at it's something the industry uses
as a piece of marketing
i don't like that box office is so
important it tends to be to hollywood
because it's again a piece of marketing
my mother who doesn't pay attention to
the industry whatsoever she knows what
the number one movie at the box office
is because it's used in the marketing of
movies
right but that's not an important number
because that number is is irrelevant
because due to inflation if adjusted to
inflation and you can look this up gone
with the wind is in the top films not
whatever the top the purported top films
are
right
um i
so i you know because we're not privy to
a lot of the data from these streaming
services we really don't know
what is incredibly popular but they
wouldn't be making
so many of these series if they weren't
at least getting numbers that got the
eyeballs they needed to
be somewhat profitable
but but we're we're
but because we're as the general public
not privy to those numbers there aren't
we're not
given other than the people who have
access to those to that data we're not
able to learn the lessons from that
there are lessons to be learned about
the failure of something like terminator
dark fate right there's a lesson to be
learned there i don't think hollywood's
quite learned the lesson yet
um
so
you know uh
that's kind of how we learn right you
see what resonates with an audience
um
and box office is one barometer of that
adjusted to inflation
i think is is the better way to to
report those numbers
do you have more hope for the future of
television or film
i i certainly have hope for the future
of television there are
i i think that statistically speaking if
i
watch something on television and i vet
that choice the you know the idea that
i'll have a good experience with a show
based on recommendations friend
recommendations
tends to tends to to hit more often than
not with the movies not so much with the
movies it's probably 50 50 or less
you know that will be a decent
experience if i know what i'm getting
into
um
i am a person that does
enjoy a good bad film
why
good good bad films are uh
just i mean look
there's certain kind of television that
is
made for stoners
right i mean like
i think a show like archer that's the
animated show archer that's
that's like stoner tv i mean you know
most of the adult swim shows
are for stoners right
they're sort of a good bat i mean like
uh tim and eric their show is kind of
based on that right so and there are
films i tend to like but i know that
they're bad
uh trauma movies
uh
you know by lloyd kaufman one of the
longest
you know existing independent film
studios is trauma studios
you know what you're getting into
you also should be aware that james gunn
from the suicide squad and the guardians
of the galaxy franchise he began his
career at troma studios he wrote tromeo
and juliet
so i kinda like if i know it's gonna be
bad it's not like something that's gonna
change my life
but i will laugh and i don't have to be
fully engaged in it except for you know
maybe the scenes where there's
lots of gore or violence which you can
always count on in a trauma movie
but that's the place where a lot of
people cut their teeth is in the
exploitation genre everyone from james
gunn
francis ford coppola ron howard who
famously you know worked for roger
corman
it's a place you can play and it's okay
to fail
and it's it's
you know and and to learn the basics
i think it's just as important to watch
a bad film and take the lessons from it
as it is to watch a good film
so
the night why are 99 of movies garbage
well you know sometimes they're
sometimes garbage movies are made on
purpose
there's a there's a big business in that
just ask lloyd kaufman
or charlie band
full moon entertainment
you know famously done
most famously known for the puppet
master series
love the puppet master films they're
they're dumb fun
so
so i think it's kind of like just
knowing what you
you know
you can't eat steak for dinner
at every meal
right
sometimes some fast food
or quick meals are going to work their
way in
and that's what i consider a bad movie
i just want to know i'm getting one
unlike
terminator dark fate where i go into
every movie hopeful go into every movie
hopeful it's going to be awesome
and it's it's not
when an artist wins a razzy
how much of it do you think was actually
planned or none of it i mean does anyone
really want to win i don't i don't know
that anyone ever wants to win a razzie
um
i mean uh
showgirls wanna razzy
uh
and and
you know i mean that film
actually we look at now there's so much
more going on in that film show girls
there are bad movies that age
differently maybe they were ahead of its
time they're ahead of their time
like a film like the original blade
runner or a film like show girls that
like there was much more going on
beneath the surface
uh i mean uh the trans community in
particular has embraced the movie uh
showgirls as
um
just having much deeper meaning there's
a documentary that discusses this that i
highly recommend that you check out
called you don't know me nomi
check out that documentary that's a a
whole um deep dive analysis of show
girls sort of re-examination
of that
additionally like why there's a whole
fandom around showgirls which i find
fascinating
great documentary that breaks that apart
and looks at it
but we just don't know like what's gonna
what's gonna age well with time right
like what's going to defy what will be a
cult classic which no filmmaker wants to
win a razzy or have a film that's called
a cult classic because both of those
things imply that you failed and i don't
think i've ever met a filmmaker
that tried to make a bad movie
although i will say this john waters has
a great quote about that
john waters said you know if you try to
make a bad film you can't fail
what does a good opening of a movie have
to have it's just really simple i want
to know what's going to happen next
and i and i can't tell you how many
times i've seen the first 5 or 10
minutes of a movie and i don't want to
watch the rest of it for a couple years
i was a programmer at the sonoma
valley film festival
and
was a program director and i watched
films
and you can tell within the first few
minutes
i you re you want to know what's going
to happen next you have to be engaged
you you have to be drawn in it's got to
be something emotional you have to
connect
and and
you just really have to know what hap
what's gonna happen next you can have
like
i mean look you can have like a great
opening and and
that can actually if you don't have that
great opening it's not gonna propel the
rest of the film because the middle of
the movie can get muddled i think
middles of films are tough
but if you blow the opening i mean
there's no point in watching the rest i
can't tell you how many first 10 minutes
of movies i've watched
so you have to grab the viewer in the
first 10 minutes
um and it really comes to do i want to
know
do i want to continue on the story with
this this character
can you think of one that's like the
perfect opening
that stands out as a model that you
would
never feel you could live up against see
my taste is so weird i'm a terrible
person to ask that question
um
of what's what's a great opening
but i'll say that probably one of my
favorite independent films of all time
is richard linklater's slacker
it's a totally non-traditional narrative
it follows different people's stories
sort of set in a day in austin texas
it's very much a the flavor of that town
at that time
and i love that movie
i don't know what it is i think it's you
know some of the stories are more
engaging than others but just
just i want to live in that world um so
[Music]
so that's a terrible example um
because it's not a traditional
narrative structure it's a series of
pieces of stories
leading you through slice of life truly
slice of life but
god
what are three mistakes that most
filmmakers or screenwriters make in the
first act of a film
i
well
i would say that the biggest mistake
that i see that a filmmaker will make in
the first act is
sort of a lack of world building to me
i would say that this probably applies
more to genre pictures
world building is incredibly important
to set up those rules set up
expectations and defy those expectations
uh and and
if you if you have not established that
nothing in the
you know the rest of the film is going
to work so in that first act world
building incredibly important
what are you looking for in a story
what i always look for in a story is um
take me on a journey and make me feel
something i want to feel moved
i don't have to agree with everything in
the film
but i want to
be taken on a journey where
i'll feel different out the other side i
think the films that have always like
impressed me the most are the ones that
have
just made me look at life differently
there's a short list of films that fit
that category i would say that um spike
lees do the right thing is one for me
that i remember when i saw that film
when i was a kid it blew my mind it
changed my change my perspective of the
world it has an incredible opening scene
um with that that music blaring it's
just like it's it's that title sequence
is so incredible um
but
it also there's a sweetness to that
world and um
it's it's it's such a it's such an
original vision
um i don't know like like i remember
seeing that film and just feeling
different afterwards and
and um i mean that applies to other like
more mainstream movies like a star wars
you know or a lord of the rings
but
make me feel something make you know
move me in some way
um
and and surprise me
make me want to go on this journey and
then
you know if we're lucky
i've i have a changed perspective
what is the purpose of story
wow that is such a that's such a these
are big questions you're asking
i i i really believe that the purpose of
stories is for us to experience things
we may never experience in our lifetime
as a way for us to heal based on our own
personal experience
so
experiencing a story that may have to do
with the death of a loved one
may help myself
deal with the loss of a loved one in my
own life i feel like there's almost
films
when i've talked to friends and they'll
say they're going through some
you know trouble you know whether it be
work related or
you know
love life or
or whatnot or something tragic that's
happened i often prescribe a movie
because
through the experience of a character in
a film we can help heal a part of
ourselves and that's what i think story
is about to to impart those lessons in a
way that's safe
you know i've never been to war
you know i've never experienced what
it's like to be
um in war i've had relatives my
grandfather fought in world war ii he
was in the navy
i had an uncle who was in vietnam
um
and
you know
having never gone through that
experience i won't know what that's like
but having experienced films like saving
private ryan
dunkirk some of the great war films
platoon among others you know
oliver stone's platoon um
like
i i you know
those visceral war films really put you
in that seat full metal jacket by
stanley kubrick like
so that comes to mind i'm grateful that
i've never
you know
had that kind of experience um
but i do think that that um really the
purpose is to for
to teach us things and to hopefully
teach us something about ourselves
um and
a really good movie it's just a very
personal experience that's why i think
people get offended
by bad reviews
and by that i mean um
as someone who has spent a good chunk of
my career as a critic
uh what's weird is the reaction of
people
when they look at your reviews
for example
no one gets angry at someone who gives a
bad review to a car
in consumer reports
or a bad review of a food from a
restaurant
right
but when it comes to something like film
if you give a bad review it's like a
personal attack
but i i believe i like when someone has
a completely different opinion from my
own i feel it's an opportunity for me to
learn something about
that person
i don't i i wouldn't say to someone who
disagrees with me about an opinion that
i have about a film that they're wrong i
want to hear what their justifications
are for how they came to that conclusion
but i do find it humorous sometimes that
people will be angry
for having a strong opinion about a
movie
um
i think that that's a personal choice
and
i i so i find that very strange
do you think that you're able to
withstand
um
punches more maybe some people are too
sensitive yeah i do think that me not
giving a is really helpful in the
sense that it's like it's like a
shield that protects me from just not
caring what other people think i think
that that's i think the longer you think
what other people think that can be that
can be creatively crippling
and so i try to avoid that at all costs
try to avoid like
giving a what people think i mean
you know
it's it's um a worthless exercise
i like that writing a prescription for
cinema
yeah i mean look i've had friends that
are just like oh you're going through
this oh you should watch that movie with
george clooney up in the air you just
lost your job that one was good jerry
maguire is probably good too you know
what i mean like life is a house yeah
just yeah stuff like like it's just like
um
yeah i mean you know here's a
prescription for you're going through
this thing
having a problem like an anne landers
column which i don't even know if that
exists anymore like an advice column but
you're prescribing movies instead of
advice
um but yeah i know there's certain
movies like i'll watch over and over
again
that i think kind of helped me i mean i
know for a fact like it is there is
there is such a thing as movie therapy
um and that's why i think that people
you know
that's why i think that this this
medium's not going away it's certainly
going to evolve in terms of the way we
see it
um
but
uh
yeah take two steel magnolias call me in
the morning yeah exactly yeah exactly
my 10 favorite movies
is an impossible question
and i would be like a
i i would probably short circuit i will
tell you what one of my all-time
favorite independent films is which is
the original slacker directed by richard
linklater
uh that movie
completely breaks your standard mold of
a traditional storytelling uh you know
with three act structure it's it's a day
in the life of austin texas where we
meet all types of people in all walks of
life and they kind of have intersecting
lives each story kind of crosses over
into the next and it's beautiful and
absolutely sweet and inspiring
that would be in my top 10 list
another film
would be 2001 a space odyssey directed
by stanley kubrick is probably for me
a perfect film
in the sense that
uh i saw it when i was five years old as
a kid
and it blew my mind and
i i probably watch it every few weeks
and by that i mean i uh keep it on in
the background while i'm working on on
other things but 2001 a space odyssey is
so inspiring
is so
um
beautiful and then i mean it's it's a
it's a true work of art
and we don't see a lot of films that
live up to
you know the words true work of art
these days
and i i tend to notice something new
about it every time i see it
there's something fascinating about that
film
and and just the artistry the the
cinematography the the way the way that
these special effects in that film stand
up to today there was never a special
edition
of of 2001 a space odyssey
although
pro tip if you
if you get the film on itunes
they will allow you to watch the film
with the original 1968 theatrical sound
mix which i strongly recommend
but that film
inspires me
it it it just it it i i kind of turn
inward whenever i watch that film and
think about life and death
and the cosmos and the unknown and all
the unanswerable questions that we you
know
that religion attempts to to answer for
us
that are truly unanswerable um only
perhaps by faith and that that film asks
those questions
without providing an answer which i
think is um
terrifying
so i love that movie
the original star wars
also has to be on that list
um
along with the empire strikes back
because
at the time that they were made when you
go back to filmmaking in the
1970s uh
those movies were dark
another favorite i would add to the list
see i'm actually going to get to the
list um
is taxi driver by martin scorsese um
and when you look at the films that were
being made at the time in the 1970s they
were very dark
the themes were you know this is a
post-nixon era
when
you know
really
it was it was it was
in in the shadow
of all the you know cultural cultural
upheaval of the 1960s and the 70s were
the hangover from that and still films
were very dark
um
even in the realm of you know science
fiction
and george lucas set out to to kind of
flip that
and say i'm gonna make a fairy tale for
kids because there are no heroes
in movies today
i mean at least that's what he thought
in the early 70s when he first began his
journey of writing the original star
wars film
so
that one just stands out and when i say
the original star wars the original cut
that was theatrical
theatrically released on may 25th 1977
which i saw in a theater just a few days
later that original cut is just
remarkable um and famously george lucas
did continue to cut even after it was
only released on about what a dozen
screens initially
and the empire strikes back just sort of
flipped that
um
interestingly
when george lucas set about working on
the story for the empire strikes back
and determined that his heavy
which was
considered to be you know in the initial
writing of star wars a small role darth
vader
he considered i'm going to make this the
main hero's father and present
um a dilemma that is you know in order
to
you know defeat the evil empire i have
kill my own father
and he actually consulted a child
psychologist
to learn
how this might affect children how the
idea of this might affect children you
know
we live in a time now where pop culture
is consumed so quickly
that a new disney plus series episode
will come out on a wednesday
and we've dissected every part of it
found every easter egg
and discussed it to death within 24
hours of its airing
and the same goes with the film it opens
on a thursday night friday
and
by monday
it's it's all been it's all been
discussed um
at the time that that films opened when
i was a kid and seeing movies it was a
discussion that lasted
for for some of these films years
um
logan's run i would add to that list
only as a
i don't really have a guilty pleasure
i'm just going to say logan's run
because i i like the ideas espoused in
that film
yes
it's shot in a shopping mall in dallas
with futuristic escalators
and cheesy special effects that do not
hold up
but the performance by michael york and
jenny agather is just
transcends
the poor special effects
um also an amazing score
but that film had a profound effect on
me as a kid
uh
and and i i just
love the ideas that were you know
there's there's a little bit of brave
new world
in that
um in logan's run kind of borrows from
that
and uh the theatrical version of that
movie with michael york is very
different than the novel uh by william f
nolan which i read as a third grader and
it really scarred me because it's such a
different
the book and the movie are so vastly
um
[Music]
you know i
a top ten list for me is just like so
difficult to put together i can talk
about favorite films and those kind of
change with um
change with you know what my current
thinking is about things
um
so this is an impossible question
which is what i'm happy you're asking
it's really impossible for me
for me to to respond to that with a top
ten
um but but these are some of my
favorites and and the reasons they and
they they resonate for me to today
now if boyhood had come out
when you were a child do you think that
would replace slacker is there something
nostalgic about some of it like because
you know for me i love boyhood uh it's
not that i didn't like slacker but
i thought boyhood was a masterpiece so
do you think you would have
that would have been your your one of
your top ten yeah that's interesting
point um i do think that many of the
films from uh that are in my top list or
movies that i saw
at a younger age they because they left
such a profound impression you know
films like apocalypse now um i think and
and i would also say i would add to that
list uh uh pink flamingos john waters i
saw that film when i was 16 years old
uh
i i i got a car not because i cared
about
girls i got a car because i wanted to go
to movies so
when i went to this rep this repertory
theater did a john waters
tribute and i saw pink flamingos and it
was shocking to me i couldn't believe
that people
that that you know structurally speaking
i mean yeah i guess it follows 3x
structure structure but there's so many
shocking elements in that film
you know in addition to
uh you know
glenn milstead the the drag queen divine
who is you know uh probably one of the
greatest drag queens in cinematic
history if that could be said
um but that movie had a huge effect on
me when i was 16 and then i just like
sort of went down a rabbit hole i was
fortunate enough to work at a video
store that had some of his other films i
female trouble might be
a personal
uh favorite because it's um it involves
uh
christmas day and cha-cha heels which i
thought was so weird i mean john waters
kind of opened my world up to like
movies don't have to be this way they
don't have to be hollywood films so i
would say everything from like slacker
being this small indie movie made by
this kid richard linklater in austin
texas you know that you know
just huge effect on me to like john
waters who's been a true independent his
entire career too
truthfully george lucas is an
independent filmmaker
you know i mean yes he found funding in
hollywood but his company lucasfilm was
not located in los angeles he relocated
to marin
county in northern california
specifically to get away from hollywood
i don't blame him
um but i would say that if there's if
there's a thread
uh
that all the films that had an effect on
me is they're all by
very
independent-minded voices
and
my fear with modern hollywood as it
becomes more corporatized is that those
voices will be lost
and the ability
to
express oneself
in through cinema because it's so
expensive
that those voices will be lost and and
that's what i have a real concern with
um
and and
and i i see where the 70s filmmaking in
hollywood was very independently driven
with this young
group of filmmakers everyone from
spielberg to you know lucas and scorsese
and uh coppola among others young at the
time
um
they were these new mavericks in
hollywood uh and
truly had independent voices i don't
know
if we'll see an era like that again and
it's it's disheartening to me and
and
i i hope that there is some push
to support these independent filmmakers
i do whatever i can with my
my own outlet film threat you know we
champion
these small filmmakers but they just
don't get the support
from the mass media like
whatever the latest disney marvel pixar
star wars
thing is
which tends to consume
all of the
consume the conversation of film for
that week
and um
so that's kind of been my
kind of my life's work through film
thread is just to elevate these smaller
movies i just wonder if we'll see
that same era again
if you were the head of a movie studio
what five movies would you green light
right now
well um if i was head of a movie studio
and i could green light five movies
i don't know if this is cheating
but i would green light three movies
which would be to redo the sequel
trilogy to star wars
i mean maybe that could count as one
but um i feel it was such a
dissatisfying end to
i guess what was intended to be a nine
film saga although
who knows when you're watching this
maybe they'll do 12 films
uh there'll be another star wars trilogy
but i i i would i would green like that
because that's a
safe bet
and we would we would
do it right this time um
the other thing i would do is probably
probably confederacy of dunces i think
is a is a classic book
that um
you know a a lot of people have you know
there have been false starts to getting
that
made that book turned into a movie
another one would be the chuck palahniuk
book survivor
which is a
probably you know
you know
one of his greatest books has such an
incredible scene
set during the super bowl
that if it's ever committed a film will
be incredible i don't really know how
you could
really make survey survivor would have
to be done almost in the way of fight
club
you know just like with a big budget and
just like not care uh what people think
but it's it's about a guy telling his
story into the flight recorder of a
plane where he's allowed he's he's taken
his plane hostage um he's this spiritual
guru
who has had been in trouble with the law
who now has commandeered a plane
you know and gotten everyone off the
plane so he is literally telling his
life story into the flight recorder
and it's what he's saying into the
flight recorder that's the story being
told
um
brilliant it's it's a book that i will
read every couple years just to
just to remind myself
that this is what can happen in in
writing it's amazing so i would i would
green like chuck
green light chuck palanik's
survivor
which is famously
where the the the phrase suicide girls
came from
that that name
is you know the website
was named after a line in that book
um is it that those type with sort of a
gossip yeah it's sort of like oh those
suicide girls and uh the founders of the
suicide girls website
took uh you know that line that inspired
like oh we're gonna start a website
based on that
um
so that would be one that i would do
uh i you know i i'd like to see
i don't know that a studio needs to do
this i would like to see a documentary
about marcia lucas
marsha lucas
had such a profound impact on
on filmmaking in the 70s you know she
was just respected by everyone from
francis ford coppola to martin scorsese
to
her husband george lucas there would not
be a george lucas if not for marsha
lucas
there's never been a deep dive
i believe documentary about her speaking
today about
you know i i
you can almost see there's like
hollywood before marsha lucas and after
marsha lucas the impact that she had
there's a there's a
rare and i've never seen it but i've
read articles about a rare rough cut of
the first assembly of star wars black
and white you know taken from you know
the dailies they cut it together and
it's just like and it's
an unwatchable film it's terrible
the original star wars i mean there's
like inappropriate humor which kind of
reared its head again in
episode one the phantom menace
um
but you can see the the choices that
marcia cut things out there are things
where just a few frames are cut and it
changes the dynamic of a character as
seen
in the cantina bar at most at most icely
before
you know luke skywalker and obi-wan
kenobi meet with han solo and chewbacca
han solo's sitting with this attractive
woman
and just sitting with her and she gets
up and walks away marcia lucas cut some
frames she's not there she's not even in
the movie
she
saved that film in the editing many of
the special effects in the original star
wars the reason they're so impactful is
because they're not on screen for very
long
so at the time that
that came out i mean it was it was so
fast-paced
and a lot of the effects objectively
didn't work but because they were on
screen for so brief a moment
it worked so i'd love to see a
documentary about marsha lucas
that really
really details her contribution to film
not just star wars but you know how she
was so
widely re respected you know by all the
greatest directors of the 70s um you
know and then after her parting ways
with george
um
you know she was basically ostracized i
mean she was you know working with her
was
she was just out of hollywood at that
point
so
that one is a huge shame
i'm trying to think of others there's
just
so many i would like to see um
the comic book
uh the dark knight returns
by frank miller
that four issue series
you know
zack snyder
was inspired by that when he made batman
v superman i the thing that made the
dark knight
returns so compelling was that
it it had all this history in it
it would be great to see that comic book
turned and turned into a film
um
another one
and maybe someone from marvel
is uh
is
if someone from marvel
watches this or listening listens to
this this is a comic book that no one
knows about i bring up every once in a
while it's a comic book called
strikeforce muratori
and it's about a group of people that
have superpowers they
that um it's in a far future
of
of the world where aliens invade and
they're
slaughtering humans and the humans are
losing
so
there's a program that's developed to
give people superpowers there's only one
catch you only live for about a year
so you don't know what kind of
superpower you're gonna get
um you don't know how you're gonna help
in this battle against these alien these
invading aliens
but uh
you only get to live for a year so
you're you're putting your life on the
line and sometimes you don't even live
that long so it focuses on the second
group of heroes that have gone through
this process
um it's it's a series that that marvel
did
back in the 80s never forgot that story
that it was really impactful um filled
with pathos and drama um a whole group
of i mean it was you know it just a
whole diverse group of characters all
this like the
the world's at stake but it wouldn't
really fit into the marvel universe at
all it's you know because it's just sort
of the separate
universe uh but i'd love to see that
um i guess if i'm a hollywood executive
i'm green lighting big budget
you know
franchise films
so
um maybe the marsha lucas documentary
wouldn't necessarily fit into that all
that well
but
you know god there's just so many i
i'd love to see
love to see made
what would you cancel
well i would have cancelled
probably maybe the
last five years of franchise reboots
there has
almost universally not been one that's
succeeded in a way where everyone is
like that was awesome
i mean
you know just a quick example like for
example lord of the rings
the lord of the rings trilogy not the
hobbit the lord of the rings
we don't really talk about that that
series of movies so much
the reason is there's no debate there's
no debate
people who don't like lord of the rings
i'm not a fantasy film fan right and i
wasn't a lord of the rings fan
necessarily i remember the hobbit
cartoon
by rankin bass
back in the day which used wrote an
early form of rotoscoping which is
interesting but but i was not a fan of
lord of the rings per se and that movie
made me that series of movies made me a
fan
you know it's incredible we don't really
debate about that because there's not
that much debate they're objectively
amazing films if you're a hardcore
tolkien fan yes there are nitpicks but
there's almost no debate about it but i
don't know that we'll ever stop debating
the disappointment that
um that was that star wars sequel
trilogy i feel like
that is a debate that will just continue
i just wonder will hollywood learn the
lessons i would want to go back in
almost every franchise that was rebooted
um ghostbusters
terminator dark fate uh you know
there's so many um
you know
did we need more fast and the furious
movies
you know i i i don't know
it it seems to me that these that these
franchise reboots i mean in some cases
there has too much time has elapsed
between you know they want to do another
film and and whatnot it's just because
the branding exists right there's that
recognition you know like when they you
know like when they
name
a movie after a familiar song
right like that's sort of a laziness on
the part of on the part of hollywood but
yeah i would if i could cancel or wipe
away or if i could just do the snap that
thanos did i would get rid of every
franchise reboot
post probably
92.
what about a star is born
did you see the first one
yeah a star is born well that see but
it's such a different approach
because there's
you know
it's the music world has changed
it's about being invested in those
characters
um
that i don't really think fits in that
category i think that star is born is
just a classic story
that's just like okay it's this is
familiar the bottles from familiar we're
gonna put like maybe a slight different
flavor you know i like those they have
those different flavors of coke like
vanilla cherry cherry vanilla orange
coke lime coke they do make that um
so it's familiar but with like a a twist
and
yeah i mean
that that uh stars-born movie with
bradley cooper and lady gaga is pretty
damn incredible
um
you know
i i really don't have much to say about
that one
you know except
good job bradley cooper
as the head of a movie studio what would
be your mission
and what would it be called by the way
what would your studio oh well yes it
would be called gore film okay that
would be my movie studio
and
i i would
i mean look
you have to tell stories where
it's an amazing story without the
superficial elements right
there has to be something to say about
you know
our current climate
we live in such divided times
i don't know why there are so
few films about that
why are we so divided
why is it that people
living in the same country who all want
the same things what are what why are we
so divided
now and there are
so few films that are dedicated to that
you know i i do see a lot of
documentaries and generally
the documentary films of a political
nature are generally they're on the left
or they're on the right
and it's it's really disappointing
because
as the viewer i would like to be able to
come to my own conclusion rather to be
led into one that you determined before
you started making the movie
so i'm surprised that
when you look at the kind of issues that
films from the 70s you know were were
taking on very challenging issues
i don't know why we're not doing that
now
so much of hollywood now is about
dictating some sort of predetermined
message it's not entertaining
i don't mind if some of that is is woven
in
but i do mind being told how to think
and i i think it that if if i was head
of a studio i'd not be telling my
audience how to think and i would
certainly be listening to what the
audience
wants
and maybe giving them something they
didn't expect that i hope they really
like
but certainly not pounding them over the
head with some sort of agenda
you know uh
i i think i think we're more alike than
we are different and i don't know why
we're not reminded of that
so that would that would be my mission
and to tell original stories giving
opportunity to small indie filmmakers
to tell original stories taking some
risks not every science fiction movie
needs to have
over-the-top spectacle with the fate of
the universe at stake
when you look back at some of the old
star trek episodes
there's so few special effects shots
right it's
star trek really delved into the realm
of ideas
and i'd like to see science fiction come
back to
dealing in the realm of big ideas
and you don't always need big spectacle
or big budgets to tell those stories
so do you think hollywood can learn
lessons from let's say art house cinema
or foreign films where there's a
subtlety there may still be a message
but it's it's letting it breathe it's
letting the viewer discover it whether
they're going to agree with it or not
whereas maybe in western culture we're
beating them over the head it's so overt
that there's no hiding it that it's
forced i i'm just curious what yeah i
think i think we've forgotten you know
joseph campbell and the hero's journey
you know i i
you know
i guess
so much of
films today seem like they kind of want
to break that mold there's a reason that
mold works it's kind of embedded in
human dna
you know that kind of around the fire
storytelling is is universal
and
that seems to
seems to have been forgotten um
lately
um in trying to break that mold
i'm just i'm just
you know especially when we see you know
the hero's journey for so many female
lead characters i think a disservice is
being done to
um
people who look up to those characters
because it's made to look easy
people forget how much failure there has
been in some of the iconic movie
characters everyone from luke skywalker
to
rocky people forget in the original
rocky film
rocky loses
he loses the fight now he gains respect
which is more of what that film is about
but he lost the fight in the original
raiders of the lost ark
indiana jones loses
he's tied up
his only logic is i'm going to close my
eyes to not to not get caught up in
these evil spirits that are coming out
to murder everything right he kind of
loses i mean maybe he wins in the end
because he gets he gets the ark he
doesn't really get the ark because it's
tucked away in a giant warehouse but he
loses there's something about
losing and this happens
more in indie films than it does in
hollywood movies
um you know what happened in the empire
strikes back luke lost
he lost the fight he lost his hand
you have to i really feel like if it's
not tied to character i i don't know how
the events of that film really can be
meaningful if it's not tied to some hero
character journey that you're on where
you can because we all fail in life
believe me we all fail in life
life is just i mean look it's just
learning from your failures right i mean
that's
and
i've made plenty of mistakes
in my personal and professional life um
that i've paid for and i like to think
i'm
who i am today is better that's that's
just failures failure is how we learn
and i feel like by not imbuing that
lesson
we're doing a disservice to
young moviegoers who might look up to
these heroes it really is um
it's kind of a disappointing time to see
how
franchises are being
you know
[Music]
twisted in a way that i don't think
serves the audience but but there's
something to be said for
losing
characters that lose more often than
they win
and what exactly you win
i think rocky probably being the most
obvious or best example of that because
then they just made rocky too sylvester
stallone made rocky too
and the old it's pretty much the same
movie i mean there's some little fun
differences in it but but it's the same
movie but he wins in that one he
actually wins the fight
but it's kind of the same movie they
just revisit a lot of the same stuff in
the film
but but he wins
whatever but the fact that rocky lost
but he won he had a girlfriend adrian he
wanted girlfriend even though he's kind
of his simpleton right this sort of thug
but anyone respect it wasn't about
winning that fight it was about winning
respect and that was tied to him in his
humanity and his soul and his character
and being that's why they made so many
rocky movies because that character's so
endearing
you know and and we're on that journey
that constant constant failure until the
end and then he wins the fight but but
in the first one he lost and and
almost no one remembers that if you ask
right now ask any
person you see like who won the fight in
the first rocky and it was a rocky won
the fight no he didn't